although the chamber could dismiss the
charges Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell has said the trial will go
ahead the Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court John Roberts is sworn in as chief
presiding officer and the Senators will
act as jurors the House of
Representative members could act as
prosecutors they and lawyers for the
president will cross-examine the
witnesses at least 2/3 or 67 senators
are needed to vote guilty on at least
one article of impeachment to have
Donald Trump removed from office now if
this happens the vice-president would
become President of the United States Al
Jazira senior political analyst Marwan
Bashara joins me now here in Doha Marwan
we've walked through the process that
will eventually happen but it does seem
an awfully long way off especially since
those articles of impeachment haven't
even got to the Senate yet what's going
on well clearly the Speaker of the House
wants a bargaining chip with the
Republican leadership of the Senate and
the only way she could do that is by
withholding those articles of
impeachment so that in her in her mind
there won't be a kangaroo trial in the
Senate that will simply vindicate and
declare president Trump innocent without
any serious process so they could just
would hold it indefinitely until more
information comes out and continue to
claim that the president was impeached
or they get better deal from the
Republican leadership in the Senate and
then they go to a trial that is more
conducive to our trial than a political
circus but their political circus is
arguably what this has turned into it
doesn't really appear to be about right
and wrong and and the you know evidence
or the lack thereof what is this really
about I mean the population assumes that
he's going to be exonerated by the
Senate so so so here essentially is
going to decide the fate of the Trump
presidency the electorate
because as you said what is supposed to
be a legal process what the founding
fathers of the United States asked
pleaded with future generation is that
they treat this as as a huge deal and
that they and they they judge it on its
merits not on ideological grounds of
course has not been the case neither in
the neither in the Clinton impeachment
process nor apparently in the Trump
impeachment process so I think what you
have now is a president that is very
robust and boastful of his rejection of
this kind of process and this in a way
Halle is both a condemnation of the
president but also a vindication of the
populist Donald Trump because what does
Donald Trump really stands for in this
context he stands for that democracy is
about he they elected and the people
everything else in between is a
destruction whether it is the media
whether it is the courts whether it's
the political parties even Congress in
as far as his concern is a destruction
because as a populist leader par
excellence
he thinks the majority decided and he is
the president and the only way he'll be
removed from office is by the electorate
everything else is unfair turn now the
the poll numbers are on the impeachment
process haven't really seen to be moving
one way or another Trump strategy is
arguably being incredibly effective and
that characterizes his president does it
does it not he is a disrupter he can
buck the trends and the conventional
wisdom when I sing this come to the
ultimate head the impeachment process do
you think that ultimately the u.s.
institutions as they are are able to
which stands the this force this
trumpian populist force what is the
future heralds whichever way the the
impeachment trial goes well look behind
the smokescreen if you will there is an
ongoing court unquote a civil war a
political ideological Civil War and
about the soul of America will America
be a pluralistic liberal democracy or
will it be a populist nationalist
democracy and in the latter sense
nationalists would mean more like
nativist white and so on so forth the
the earlier would mean more blacks
minorities support for free speech
defense of the institutions that are
supposed to be or have oversight over
the democratic process I think president
Trump represent that nationalist
Democratic a liberal America while more
the Democrats Congress and the courts
represent something more liberal and
pluralistic and I think here in the next
10 months or so Americans will have to
decide do they only vote by their
pockets and whether there's some
economic progress or better income tax
on Saul so forth or whether they will
vote by their conscience meaning do they
want a liberal democratic America or a
nationalist a liberal America ok Marwan
Beshara Al Jazeera's senior political
analyst thank you very much for your
thoughts